Becki starts off this hour Boise Idaho
hi Becky how are you I'm doing all right
thank you good how can I help so I have
kind of an ugly situation
I've been married 18 years we have six
kids ages 1 to 15 and my husband's been
cheating on me for years and I were
gonna get hoarse now and so we're trying
to figure out how to do this and he has
we moved to a new location for him to
take a new job but it paid less money
but it's less stressful for him and he's
got lots of issues and you know semi
suicidal frequently and whatnot so of
all these issues so he let me take the
equity from our previous house or we put
it into this new house that we bought
house cost $200,000 we put a hundred
thousand down on it so my mortgage will
be pretty reasonable which he did that
on purpose we were gonna see if we could
make the marriage work but he just can't
stop what he's doing so but that leaves
him with nothing
we did have some savings but then needed
to buy a car or a band replaced another
one and so we pretty much don't have any
savings now I mean other than a couple
of thousand dollars and he's I can't
seem to get rid of him now you know he's
so I'm wondering my question is you
can't seem to get rid of him well he
needs to move out because you know his
family does you know what he's doing and
the kids are kind of see it well what is
his what is his income about 85,000
Wiltjer income
none i'm home with the kids i've been
home with the kids for 14 years or so so
I don't have an income so I'm just gonna
be living on child support to start and
I'm going to go back to school and get a
masters degree so I can support myself
in a couple of years why do you have to
have a motto agree to support yourself
well for what I'd like to do I'd like to
go into health
counseling um so I'd need that to do
that in the meantime he he sleeps
outside in our RV so he can have his
privacy and whatnot but how come well
I'm wondering if he should take out a
loan so that he can he just won't leave
he's I think he's trying to find someone
he can move in with or something but um
- so that he can buy put some money down
he's a veteran so we have a VA loan on
this house and I don't think he can get
another VA long other than his ability
to pay child support this is the father
of 8 children who chooses to continue
six children who could choose to
continue to have affairs after 18 years
of marriage my concern for him at this
point this conversation is almost zero I
don't care what he does other than other
than pay you a big boatload of child
support and get out of there
I mean I'm over him right now and I
don't know him now so you know he can't
quit yeah you can quit he just won't so
I did change your words but um anyway
yeah I think it's it's if it's done it's
done I'm not a family counselor but this
is ridiculous
so but here's the thing I don't think
you can make it on child support and I
don't think you have the option with six
kids running around one to 15 to go back
and accentuate your education you're
gonna be working kiddo what's your
undergrad in you don't get the chance
raishin yeah you don't get that you're
gonna be a nutritionist I mean you're
gonna be making up some money to feed
this family because let me just help you
with this Bubba's not reliable he's not
reliable have you not noticed well I
mean he's always provided and his plan
with letting me have he his plan is to
let me have all the equity in the house
you have the equity in the house that's
fine but the equity in the house is
worth nothing right now if you stay in
the house if you sell the house and go
rent you have a hundred thousand dollars
in your pocket with six kids that's gone
about 20 men
right so I intend to stay here and my
plan is been to to slowly get into the
workforce and whatnot but by the time I
pay for babysitters for the two that are
at home I think that would suck most of
it up so I'm thinking if I went to
school so I could make a decent I would
like ready to make sure to make a decent
wage but you have a degree in nutrition
I say some way it's so long ago I
couldn't just become a dietician I'd
have to go we take all the classes and
then do an internship for a year and
whatnot so that's kind of that boat is
failed well I mean here's the thing I
don't think you have the luxury with
what you're describing to me - but spend
the next two years in school you're
going to be working longer doing that
because you're really short of money
kiddo I mean this counting on this gotta
pay child support I hope he does the law
says he should morally he should I get
all of that but morally shouldn't be
sleeping around on his wife
so morals don't enter into his equation
and yeah he's been he's been reliable so
far but that's until he gets a
girlfriend and she says for him not to
send the money over there and you know
that so you've got to have a game plan
here that for your career and yes you
need to see an attorney and yes the
attorney needs to explain to him he
needs to move if you're going through a
divorce that's what needs to happen or
this you know where you go back to
marriage counseling and you know he
learns to stay at home and you forgive
him and that's what you all do if that's
what you're able to do but it sounds to
me like the way you're describing this
is it's over and he's just such a weak
character that he can't seem to even
wander off but that's what you're
describing